hallo ihr lieben wir können es nicht
verhindern der winter kommt und deswegen
gibt es heute einen typischen
winterliches rezept nämlich eine suppe
wobei ich muss zugeben brokkoli super es
sich gerne das ganze jahr über
aber im winter eben verstärkter und
öfter und jetzt zeige ich euch eine
leckere brokkoli suppe fettarm und
kalorienarm
wir benötigen neben brokkoli auch
kartoffeln für die konsistenz außerdem
an gewürzen gemüse oder rinderbrühe salz
und pfeffer und das ist optional etwas
parmesan was der außerdem benötigen ist
reichlich wasser in einem kochtopf das
habe ich schon zum kochen gebracht und
gebe da jetzt brokkoli und kartoffeln
rein
[Musik]
wichtig ist dass unser gemüse
vollständig mit dem wasser bedeckt ist
ich gebe immer zuallererst eineinhalb
liter rein und dann schaue ich es kommt
immer auf die größe des gemüses an
manchmal ist der vogel etwas größer
manchmal etwas kleiner und wichtig ist
dass es eben bedeckt ist jetzt gebe ich
den deckel drauf und lass' es 15 bis 20
minuten lang köcheln
dann kann es nämlich richtig schön weich
werden und wir können es anschließend
pürieren
nach 20 minuten ist unser gemüse richtig
schön weich und fertig zum pürieren und
ich integriere brokkoli immer ganz gerne
in mein mittag oder abendessen oder
generell bei brokkoli sehr gesund ist so
cool er total viel vitamin c was jetzt
gerade im winter super ist und vor
erkältungen schützen und ganz viel
kalzium was gut für die knochen ist
jetzt werde ich das ganze erstmal
pürieren dafür räumlich kurz diesen
induktionsherd weg und dann sehen wir
uns gleich wieder wie schon erwähnt wie
die suppe jetzt püriert und anschließend
kümmern wir uns um die gewürze und das
tolle ist dass die kartoffeln dir drin
sind jetzt für die richtig schöne cremig
und sämige konsistenz sorgen
so wenn ihr das ganze püriert habt
fehlen ja nur noch die gewürze und da
könnt ihr auch ganz eigenständig handeln
da könnt ihr gucken was passt am besten
natürlich salz und pfeffer ist ein muss
ich gebe immer gerne gemüsebrühe hinzu
was auch noch gut reinpassen würde zum
beispiel muss karten und da könnt ihr
auch gerne schauen und genauso verhält
sich das auch mit der sahne
entweder nimmt die fettarme sahne oder
kondensmilch nehmen auch ganz viele
frisch kreiert frischkäse ja ganz viele
alternativen die schreibe ich euch aber
gerne auch noch mal in die infobox
[Musik]
und fertig ist die leckere kalorienarme
und gesunde brokkoli suppe ich zeige
euch jetzt lief das ganze serviere ich
gebe gerne etwas fettarme sahne in die
suppe also in den topf und dann noch mal
am tisch dann sieht es nämlich richtig
schön dass mit dem weißen kontrast was
ich außerdem gerne dazu gäbe sind je
nachdem was ich da habe geröstete
pinienkerne oder angebratene kesha kern
ist auch super lecker ich wünsche euch
jetzt ganz viel spaß beim nachmachen das
rezept die genauen mengenangaben mit
ganzen tipps und tricks findet ihr unten
in der infobox
ansonsten freue ich mich wenn ihr dem
video ein bäumchen nach oben gibt main
kanal kostenlos abonniert damit ihr auch
nichts mehr verpasst und dann freue ich
mich wenn wir uns im nächsten video
wiedersehen
[Musik]